[Music]
okay first some nightmares hello Esther
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Whitney Cummings and
this is my robot bear claw what's up
peaches bear claws new to stand up so
that's why she's sitting down with these
comics it looks like one of those toys
offering real sex was gonna happen but I
still there was a person you're moving
and then it was not and I'm sorry
time's up I need advice on how to be a
comedian will be yourself because you
know ones better than what you are
there's no one that looks like why are
there fewer female comedians other women
are is encouraged as much to be funny
yeah a young age when I look back it
growing up who were there no
that would inspire me there were a lot
of women or some but there was mostly
men mm-hmm well I'm the city image of
Mitch Hedberg so I have they call me
Dutch I've heard in the South if you can
find a nickname
Thursday far most men with testosterone
they're gonna be like and then they just
feel out of place and it's weird and
yeah you know so I think that's the
reason why there aren't a lot of female
comedians what are the main challenges
and feeding women in comedy I think the
main challenge of being a woman in
comedy is much as you work on just being
the funniest strongest hardest worker
your dm's will be filled with people
wanting to see your future look there's
always an asterisk
there's no matter how good you are like
it sounds like you're the funniest woman
comic you're the funniest trans comic
you know a female comedians meets rather
female comedian well I'm that I can't
speak for all women but I'm a very nice
person I love I feel like women in
comedy should be like a sorority it's
not a lot of us and we all do better
when we stick together I think there
should be more shows with women
collaborating and having a space for
women to do stuff just as well as the
men do sure much anyway what do I do is
the mass comedian tries to jerk off
thank me Oh will depends on whether you
want it I would make fun of their dick
and be bound for life I would be scared
I'd be horrified because I get starts
truck really easily starts on Monday
somebody put they dig out I don't care
if they rich or famous whatever I'm
slapping I'm slapping the shit out I
would hope to have the strength more
than things changing are living in
comedy or not there's more women
stepping out there and that's what I
always say to women that do comedy I was
like listen they can't do that shit we
chose to get up on the stage and do the
shit and tell our truth and there's more
women taking that leap and I think it's
great and I try to show that yes what's
the deal with airplane food what is the
deal that was funny is that the whole
joke you see last like a comment thank
you for the advice lady alright good
luck to you thank you for you
great thank you well one of you bitches
please come fucking get me while female
comics really don't help other female
comics
[Music]